year's eve is certainly going to be a
whole lot different for almost everyone
all around the world including right
here
in new york city's times square where
the only members of the small live
audience for the city's iconic ball drop
will be a select few front-line workers
and their families we wanted to
celebrate our heroes of 2020
and their families these are first
responders frontline and essential
workers who sacrifice so much
to provide care and support for our
communities and they represent
the same families throughout our country
and all over the world who have
sacrificed in 2020
to protect us and to help to help their
communities we celebrate them tonight
aisha hosni is live in new york city
with the details and wow what a
different sight behind you this year
hey julie yeah it is a bizarre sight
definitely take a look right behind me
by now we would already see
hundreds of thousands of spectators here
filing in for the ball drop but
hardly a soul inside it is eerie eight
blocks of times square shut down today
because
this year there will be no spectators
allowed because of corona virus you'll
have to watch the ball drop
on tv or online only 40 first responders
and essential workers as you mentioned
will be allowed to watch
live in person the city's way of saying
thank you with fewer people there will
be
80 percent fewer cops in times square
but security is tight with the nashville
bombing top of
mind nypd's counterterrorism bureau has
already put up
some concrete barriers sweep parking
garages with much more
on the agenda in the next couple of
hours
okay officers will also secure entry
point screening
for cast and production teams this will
be a multi-layered process
at these designated locations that
include magnetometer screening
and explosive detection screen teams
other assets
we will be deploying include in the
inner and outer perimeter of the event
heavy weapons teams bomb squad and
critical
response commands explosion detection
canines
drone detection teams blocker vehicles
and department of sanitation sand trucks
a lot going on but the show must go on
julie the iconic ball will still be
dropping at midnight and there will be
live performances by
andrea day pitbull and gloria gainer
performing her
global hit i will survive julie i know
that we will all be
singing along to that one oh my god yes
we will thank you so much eisner